Anthony are you an actor or a
businessman what a cool question
can I call up a couple ex-girlfriends
and you can ask me that again sure we
actually got there FIBA Nam Oh perfect
um I think you got a say businessman
because sole proprietor everything I do
everything written everything I produced
everything that I've kind of in its you
know it's still me and it sounds weird
to say because it's gonna sound it's
just gonna sound weird to say coming out
my mouth it's like you almost have to do
build your brand as small as it may be
you know you get you have to start
somewhere with it and in terms of
business it's like yeah this is what I
do I've been fortunate enough where I've
gotten paid money to be in front of the
camera or behind it or write something
down that someone else is gonna read and
make it even better and it all stems
from me so yeah businessman when you
were planning your trip here and while
you were still in Chicago were you
researching not just places to live and
and possibly work part time to get your
feet off the ground but also how you
would go about it and did you see that
as yeah there was I kind of wrote out a
six-month plan
Wow that was like well it was it was
gonna be I'm gonna hit the ground
running here's what I hope to accomplish
in six months it was realistic stuff it
wasn't like you know star opposite
George Clooney in oceans 14 or anything
like that like it was actually realistic
things right which would be cool by the
way and it was one of those where I
wanted to check off these and get my
foot into this door and see if I you
know perform comedy again or write
something for this and I did more in the
first six months than I thought I would
do in like the first two years so it
could have been dumb luck and could have
been the right timing which is half the
game out here but whatever it was it it
opened up my eyes to be like okay I did
more than I thought I would in the first
six months let's keep this you know ball
rolling have you always been a goal
writer have you always written your
goals down oh yeah yeah goal writer
dreamer
whatever you want to call it from an
early age on even with sports
even with sports being overweight as a
young kid I mean like I want to lose
weight went outside and ran with trash
bags on until I lost the late
voluntarily by the way it's like child
abuse nowadays did it on my own but
little things like that yeah just set a
realistic goal and I think if you do
that even if you don't obtain exactly
what you went for you're still gonna get
something out of it especially out here
if you're moving all these little chess
pieces around sometimes like you said
the social media thing is someone down
the road might look at something and be
like ah this was hilarious he's funnier
than that dude in Cincinnati call back
from earlier where did you where did you
get that idea to write stuff down
because I've seen people that plan it
but it's all of yeah that's all that
mattered is very post-it note II just
like here's what you got to do let's get
this done like you said I think it comes
actually from a sports background you
know cuz everything's set on a schedule
and you know you're measured in wins and
losses and it's it's a barometer for how
good you and your team are it's a it's
kind of a good measuring stick I think
it's actually just some stems from that
really but yeah just and also it's been
a blessing and a curse that been able to
do different things like you know
there's people that just strictly want
to act which is absolutely fantastic
I kind of have interest in a lot of
things when I got out here it was
equally doing each one and you know
whichever one actually takes the best
then whichever one's working the best
the other two are gonna feed off of it
it's just I like that portion of it yeah
do you still have that not a manifesto
but contract with yourself you still
have it somewhere uh packed away in one
of those awesome folders that are
probably still duct-taped together from
like Spanish class freshman year in high
school
oh I mean for the acting one sorry oh I
was too big do you still have that the
acting of contract that you made with
yourself somewhere here yeah that's it's
weird well I guess not weird weird slash
cool there was just like a list of
things I made when I was like 16 years
old that I thought I always wanted to do
and the response to stuff on there and
one of them was like la and act right
comedy and I hit all of them because
they were realistic like I said it
wasn't like you know win the hundred
meters in the Olympics yet there's still
time still time
you